right denise get a little this those
winds that have been whipping through
the valley all day blew down a billboard
downtown this is at eighth street in
bonanza i guess they don't make signs
like they used to yes right yeah i mean
they're really whipping up on saturdays
it's not as bad today really we've been
whipping up every day right since since
friday so maybe the wind is just taking
it up a notch yeah really and then we're
not done yet either because we have
another round again this week as well
one thing you got to worry about too i
remember denise you didn't believe me on
this trampolines yes trampolines until i
saw it with my own eyes they can blow
around
that's like a sail too and this could be
dangerous and the last thing you want is
the temp the trampoline to blow around
while somebody's on it no that's the
last thing right you put those sandbags
on there you go that's what i did at my
house of course those winds now starting
to degrade look at the shot i love the
shot here the strat look at that clear
skies for tonight winds the good news
the winds are starting to decrease a
little bit here are top gusts from
earlier today read at 43 miles per hour
north las vegas 39 36 southern highlands
henderson 31 that does not surprise me
that that billboard came down because it
acts like a sale all right those it's an
older billboard you get a good gust
that's going to bring down that
billboard that's what we saw for the day
today currently outside 53 sky canyon
same for you and centennial hills 56
spring valley north las vegas 56 for you
as well 60 on the east side 60 for
whitney ranch in green valley 55 double
fives for you and henderson and same for
mountains edge and rhodes ranch
currently outside 53 for prompt outside
the valley 55 boulder city and 61 for
you joining us from down river and
laflin here's our radar network that low
now spinning off towards the east still
some snow associated with this one in
arizona while we remain dry we've got
that cold northerly flow with that flow
we'll see another system dive down this
is going to be by midweek and impact
this on wednesday and thursday as far as
rain chances go watching it not really a
big chance for us here but remember each
day that forecast evolves it changes so
that's why you're gonna have to watch us
every day to see if that changes the
other big story of course is the roller
coaster temps look at that little roller
coaster going up and then down again
with that system with that temperature
drop on thursday and then goes up again
as we head into the weekend so you can
really feel it wednesday's going to feel
nice thursday not so much
overnight low is going to be chilly
throughout many of our neighborhoods 35
in summerlin 37 southern highlands the
lakes and spring valley 38 along with
downtown and north las vegas 37 for
those of you in henderson so not quite
the freezing mark but still near it just
a couple days above the freezing mark 28
and cold for you boulder city 37
tomorrow morning so here's your forecast
39 degrees chilly and breezy but the
winds will decrease tomorrow 62 degrees
tomorrow cool and sunny so a little
improvement temperatures will warm up
your eight day forecast looking ahead so
we warm up to 70. look at that near 70.
some neighborhoods will hit 70s by
wednesday and then reality sets in again
dropping us back to the 55 range and
then don't forget to push your clocks
back one hour on the weekend for
saturday and sunday wait i will call you
guys back spring forward spring forward
sprinkler yeah
when you wake up sunday and it's 8 a.m
it's actually 9 a.m so what's gonna
happen is your phone will do that for
you okay and i will call you the night
before please do thank you ted all right